bonsoir messieurs merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france à leur
première question douglas y est pourquoi
les états unis ont décidé de réduire
leur présence militaire au moyen-orient
globalement on avait du gain qui était
en échec et ira de guerre qui s'était
monté pendant l'origine de george bush
et retiers par le régime obama qui n'a
jamais réussi à sortir et continuer à
l'origine 30
malheureusement pour lui qui n'aime pas
donc après vingt ans de guerre si le
moment deux parties mais aussi en avait
une présence des batteries anti missiles
qui s'était installé à cause des
tensions avec iran et l annonce par le
sac retient le ministère de défense
comme aux états unis
aussi indique qu'il ya un désir une
vraie des yeux de death escale à sion
des tensions dans la région alors après
avoir renforcé leur présence militaire
en 2019 et 2020 en raison de tensions
avec l'iran vous en parliez en douglas
et yates
il décide aujourd'hui les américains de
la réduire cette présence militaire à ce
que cela signifie que les tensions entre
téhéran et washington sont plus apaisées
aujourd'hui us ben bella bonsoir moi je
trouve que cette décision en fin de
compte entre dans un cadre de
désengagement militaire des etats-unis
de tout le moyen orient bien sûr on peut
expliquer la décision par rapport à des
raisons budgétaires liés également au
budget de l'armement américain et de
l'orientation de cette de ce budget sur
suippe par rapport à une crise sanitaire
et économique inédite par rapport à
l'administration
by day mais je crois que le
désengagement il est omniprésent pour
les états unis parce qu'il ya un intérêt
vers d'autres régions du monde notamment
l'asie l'océan indien est également un
intérêt récemment vera vers l'afrique en
voit qui est un renforcement par rapport
à des capacités d'africom a des
capacités pour les les forces
d'intervention militaire américaine par
exemple en afrique ou bien en asie pour
contrecarrer la chine maintenant ce qui
se passe en moyenne hors ayant
effectivement il y aura des
répercussions par rapport aux dossiers
nucléaires iranien ou là où il ya une
volonté américaine de l'administration
byden de finir avec avec ce conflit est
de trouver à une résolution avec avec
avec l'iran mais ce désengagement ne
veut pas dire en fin de compte un repli
américain parce qu'il sera remplacé par
d'autres alliés des etats unis dans
cette région c'est à dire les puissances
régionales
les alliés des etats-unis notamment la
turquie qui est un allié dans l'otan
avec avec les états unis et israël est
également les pays du golfe mais là
j'aimerais bien souligné que le
désengagement américain sera
certainement une opportunité
intéressante pour une grande deux
puissances comme la chine d'avoir une
expansion dans cette région et je crois
que la chine c'est le nouveau acteur
actuellement dans le dans le moyenne le
moyen orient la chine elle a un
partenariat stratégique de 450 milliards
de dollars avec avec les ronces et le
premier fournisseur d'endettement
pour romain c'est le premier partenaire
technologique des émirats arabes unis
elle construit une station nucléaire de
80 milliards de dollars avec l'arabie
saoudite c'est également le premier
investisseur dont le le monde arabe donc
effectivement on voit qu'il ya un moyen
orient en transition voire même en
transformation ce qui implique qu'il y
aura également un nouveau alliés qui est
la chine est bien évidemment avec son
partenaire la russie qui a déjà un pied
et qu'il ya déjà une pierre
d'achoppement en en série donc ce qui
signifie qu'il y ait certaines
transformations on va dire du paysage du
moyen-orient parce que les enjeux ont
changé et également les intérêts ont
changé douglas y est ce que vous pensez
comme younès ben c'est là que pékin a du
souci à se faire et que ce retrait
américain va automatiquement placé la
chine dans le viseur américain oui c'est
certain que maintenant mairie d'orly
avec la chine est la préoccupation
majeure stratégique des états unis vingt
ans - orient sans ouvrir objectif
apprendre une rhétorique démocratique
les etats unis occupent perdu le sens de
la politique étrangère moyen orient de
sommes entrés nationale des etats unis
c'est du pétrole et ils peuvent bien
avec une négociation d'une accorde avec
ira et avec leurs alliances avec les
pays du golfe persique a provisionné du
prétoire
sans jouer de jeu démocratique dans la
région
oui maintenant je suis complètement
d'accord l'objectif c'est le rival riz
avec la chine et a laissé la chine
prendre le boîte de pandore 1-2 -
orientaux rivard parce que les états
unis ont trouvé comme les moussons
découvrir
afghanistan c'est là sa métier à des
empires younès ben fait la belle fait là
comment vous pensez que pékin va réagir
à ce peut-être nouveau positionnement
des américains à son égard d'abord la
stratégie chinoise il est pas basé sur
le hardcore c'est à dire sur le
renforcement militaire ou bien sur des
bases militaires dans dans ce genre de
région mais elle est basée seulement sur
des raisons ou des intérêts économiques
à travers l'investissement à travers une
manne financière intéressante sans
ressemble à ce qui s'était passé en
afrique dans l'est dans les dix
dernières années la chine
actuellement elle a des investissements
par exemple en afrique 275 milliards de
dollars c'est c'est à peu près les
investissements des états unis de la
grande bretagne est également de la
france en commun donc ce qui fait que
quand on voit qu'il ya une nouvelle
stratégie chinoise par rapport à cette
région parce que également les intérêts
sans changer les intérêts sans changer
effectivement la question de pétrole
n'est plus d'actualité maintenant on
s'intéresse plus au gaz c'est pour ça
que l'intérêt part vers la méditerranée
orientale plus que les pays et les pays
du golfe
il ya également un autre facteur que je
trouve très intéressant qui est la
géopolitique des ports ou bien la
géopolitique des détroits donc l'intérêt
vers le détroit d'ormuz ou bien aux
oyats mails sont des points vraiment
stratégique pour gérer le commerce
international surtout que la chine elle
a un grand projet qui s'appelle la route
de la soie et c'est un projet qui passe
par 62 pays avec lequel la chine a
essayé d'accaparer en quelque sorte tout
le commerce international donc ce qui
fait que là on est face à une guerre on
va dire de puissance mais je confirme
que les états unis se retire mans on se
replie ne veut pas dire qu'il ya un
retrait américain mais ce sera une
gestion par délégation donc il faut
vraiment être attentif par rapport aux
efforts qui sont placés chez les turcs
par exemple bien les israéliens au biel
des pays en comme les pays du les pays
du golfe qui vont certainement remplacer
ce rôle américain dans cette région de
glace yates on sait que le terrorisme
est présent dans certaines régions du
monde est ce que les états unis peuvent
être amené à regretter bien d'avoir
décidé de se retirer de certaines
régions
c'est difficile avec le guerre contre le
tien parce que ce n'est pas vraiment un
gain
on n'a pas vraiment un objectif
militaire donc jamais une victoire mais
ce que les états unis en chercher et que
la chine aussi va continuer comme
souvent c'est la stabilité et l'idée que
le le les terroristes peuvent utiliser
le moyen orient comme une base
d'organisation pour les fondent pour les
hommes et le reste oui ça va causer des
regrets mais je crois le longtin les
sons c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire kong
et 1 contre en chimères qu'on peut faire
en guerre contre un ennemi n est apte
une mouvement mais contre une idée non
jamais donc c'est la stabilité que les
états unis cherchent et je pense que mon
collègue a bien dit les états unis
continuent à voir des forces militaires
à tous dans le monde et utiliser le
pouvoir fait le pouvoir militaire reste
l'enjeu principal des états unis lunesse
benfeld a comme à ce que les pays arabes
au prix la nouvelle de ce retrait des
forces américaines au moyen orient
moi je crois qui a des relations
historiques et stratégies contre les
pays arabes et les états unis mais
certainement ce genre de décision un
billet sur 100 agents des écoles négatif
chez les dirigeants surtout du monde
arabe parce qu'ils se sont qui sont
vraiment laissé dont des cas
d'instabilité surtout avec la dernière
décennie qui était très très dure ce
qu'on a appelé le printemps arabe après
les guerres civiles dans la majorité des
pays arabes est effectivement avec des
projets d'expansion stratégique soit par
la turquie ou bien même par par l'iran
donc ce qui fait que on n'est vraiment
pas ça
changement un nouveau moyen orient qui
est en train de se dessiner mais
effectivement je crois que l'entrée de
la chine dans cette dans cette région va
chercher la stabilité surtout que la
chine n'a jamais demandé à ses alliés de
faire des efforts par exemple sur la
question des droits de l'homme bien sûr
la question de la démocratie
c'est ce qui fait la différence avec
avec les américains ce su que la
stratégie américaine était toujours on
va dire et toujours avec des avec des
valeurs occidentales liés à ces à ce
jour de questions c'est à dire la
question soit de la démocratie soit la
question du changement politique la
participation des jeunes des femmes ou
au pouvoir maintenant c'est ça ce qui
est vraiment inquiétant par rapport à
une autre île chinoise dont dont sept
dans cette région là où on peut dire que
c'est une région qui est poudrière de
conflit mais également aussi fragilement
on va dire en matière d'institutions
c'est-à-dire ce genre dans ce genre de
région on n'a que des milices ou on a
connu dirigeants dictateurs qui ont le
pouvoir maintenant
l'institutionnalisation des états
certainement c'est l'enjeu pour tous et
ces pays arabes afin de faire face avec
avec l'entrée des nouvelles puissances
soient les puissances est régionale ou
bien même les puissants ce mondial
douglas y est c'est le bon moment pour
les états unis de se retirer du
moyen-orient quand on fait le bilan des
dernières tensions entre israël et le
peuple palestinien ou encore de la crise
au liban
oui un couche de l'un chante du procès
gains et a sans fin et on a besoin des
investissements domestiques aux
etats-unis dans l'infrastructure dans le
monde économique
oui c'est le beau mon mandat a été cette
farce de politique est politique
étrangère dans cette région en a dix
autres objectifs à accomplir
vous êtes d'accord lyonnaise ben faleh
belle fait à part dont les états unis
vont se retirer ça va permettre aux aux
états de reprendre un petit peu leur
souveraineté de gérer
eux mêmes leurs propres conflits ils en
sont qu'à deux marches non je suis pas
super optimiste là dessus je crois que
la question de la de la souverainté
dépend de plusieurs facteurs qui sont
liées à la construction on va dire de
l'état en matière d'institutions à la
démocratie à des projets de
développement certes il ya des projets
on va dire intéressant ambitieux chez
certains pays ou aux médias lorient mais
la majorité écrasante des pays sont dans
une situation vraiment déstabilisante et
donc ce qui fait que les états unis
étaient partie prenante en quelque sorte
du tout ce qui s'était passé dans les
dents les dernières dans les dernières
années surtout les trois dernières
décennies
donc je crois que ça va demander
énormément de temps pour reconstruire la
relation de confiance soit vis-à-vis des
etats-unis ou bien vers d'autres vers
d'autres pays mais je crois que les
gagnants en quelque sorte de ce
désengagement c'est certainement la
chine et la russie ses deux alliés qui
ont une stratégie très intéressante qui
est basée seulement sur le fait de
d'optimiser ou de profiter des erreurs
des américains dans le dans le
moyen-orient afin de chercher désaltérer
à long terme j'aimerais bien le dire je
suis désolé à l'interview touche à sa
fin je vais vous remercier à younes
benfeld âge rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en relations internationales
spécialiste du monde arabe
merci à vous également douglas y est
professeur de droit et spécialiste de la
politique américaine